a Metal Gear Solid 3 remake is very
exciting but can we trust Konami to do
it
let's talk about it
[Music]
Tam congratulations thank you what am I
being congratulated for you enjoy you're
a metal gear enjoyer I am a known Metal
Gear Leica yeah Mel Gibb
um I would describe myself as a metal
gear pervert Metal Gear is like a huge
part of my history as a video game fan
as a writer it's the game that made me
wanna
write about games all the time and like
think about them on a more critical
level it's one of my defining features
yes you know when people are like I'm
about to make this my entire personality
that was me when the original came out
on the PlayStation so Metal Gear Solid 3
in remade was an at the PlayStation
showcase this week we were in this very
room we were very excited when we saw it
you stood up I did stand up we stood up
with excitement I think I had the
knee-jerk reaction that all metal gear
fans have oh it's metal gear and then
the moment that passed I was like oh no
it's metal gear it's a new version of a
beloved classic game what people have
been asking for a really long time or at
least
play it yeah I think people will like
let us play this game they took away the
HD uh remakes or HD versions of those
and then they saw the Pachinko thing and
they were like that would be cool Lord I
have seen what you have given to others
here's the thing in the industry Gamers
they'll ask for something that they want
up until they get it and at that point
they'll be like should we have asked for
this yeah
that is very much where we where we're
at with this now Metal Gear 23 one of
the best games ever made being remade
for modern consoles PC brief teaser
showed animals munching on each other
and then at the end naked snakes emerges
from the darkness and then we get the
Cynthia Harold Snake Eater which is
great exciting very exciting on his face
exciting to see the trailer
but then
the issues begin who is making this and
why are they making it
so we were sat in here yesterday and we
were doing some Googling you were
getting press releases from Konami we
were taking a look nowhere does it
mention who is making this game the
statement on konami's website just
refers to development team I even went
on LinkedIn okay we don't know any names
attached but we know who we know a name
that's not definitely not attached and
that name is hirokojima the author one
of the masterminds behind metal gear
solid as a whole before we you know
upset people who are you don't like the
authors kind of approach to discussions
we understand that he worked with a team
melgo solid is often written with
writing partners
umarata and tomokazu Fukushima worked on
metal gear73 Morata went on to work on
death stranding so he has collaborators
but also he is the director of a lot of
these games and his stamp his his kind
of identities on there there's no
mention of Kojima anywhere and that is
concerning for a bunch of reasons for a
game like this Legendary game legendary
franchise one of the greatest games of
all time there needs to be some level of
credibility attached to it yep and one
of the easiest way users you do that is
that you pay homage to the people that
came before or you say something as
simple as we are talking to Kojima he's
advising he's something like that you
work something out that's not happening
and given this very public Fallout
between Kojima and Konami it's not a
surprise that it's not happening no
mention of him on box Arts now like they
actively removed that there's periods on
their financial website where they have
certain things removed because they
provide evidence of Kojima being a very
high level executive in Konami they like
push that aside and they delete it so
there's very little wow yeah they fully
scorched the Earth and we know what
kojima's
kind of feelings on this is Mel Gear
Solid ground zeros had a mission where
you went around and you erased the names
of real Metal Gear games and left fake
ones PT for example is like there's been
enough discussion and yeah theorizing
around it PT is basically his experience
of being ostracized from Konami and has
there been anything that has changed or
has there been optically anything that's
happened that has changed our feelings
or our perception our understanding of
the Konami that was to this day well to
add to that the Konami we know now it's
not necessarily a video game publisher
or developer they made a conscious
decision to get out of video games AAA
video games part of that was because a
lot of money was spent on Fox engine on
Metal Gear Solid 5 and you know that
team had no signs of slowing down they
were making PT with Guillermo del Toro
and Norman Reedus that is going to cost
money at the same time they started down
this path of mobile games
microtransactions which were big at the
time and they were making money hand
over fist like they were making the
money that was being spent on these
games in like a fraction of the time
which naturally means Executives start
looking at things and going why are we
making this game which costs hundreds of
millions and takes freaking years when
we can play this mobile game and make
hundreds of millions in half that time
they were very public with this move
more into mobile games microtransactions
yeah and you can see if you look now at
konami's website Wikipedia on latest
releases
mobile games and e-football formerly
known as Pro Evolution Soccer because
guess what you can jam microtransactions
in a soccer football based game and no
one gives the first game that they made
without Kojima was survive and it is
littered with micro transactions yeah
you had to pay for a second save slot in
that game which is unreal Metal Gear
survive is a very sore subject for Tam
yeah I reviewed that game I cried the
entire time economy of today that we
just saw announced a Metal Gear Solid 3
is a Konami that hasn't made a triple A
game in a really long time is unwilling
to tell us who is making the game
and released a trailer
that feels like it tried to be a Kojima
trailer and they showed off nothing they
gave us nothing I also am willing to see
what happens oh yeah a game can be
remade without the kind of Mastermind
developer and we've seen it happen
before we've seen it happen before so we
had Dead Space remake Resident Evil 4
remake then we have a studio like blue
point and this is why when we're kind of
not complaining but you know mentioning
how it's concerning that they're not
mentioning a developer if you attach a
studio like blue point who is so well
known and well renowned for re-making
games like look what they did with Demon
Souls look what they did with Shadow of
the Colossus they've even touched Metal
Gear Solid right and that's why for a
long time when rumors of the Metal Gear
Solid remake everyone thought hey it was
going to be one and B the blue point
we're going to be making it and now
we're getting a three remake with no
name no name to end let's be honest
there's a reason why they're not telling
us their name yeah like if you were
proud of it you would say these these
are the people who are attached to it if
it was blue point you wouldn't hide that
fact unless maybe we'll eat crow and
like a week from now they'll be like hey
here's our big reveal of the developer
or it's a marketing beat which is if
that is a marketing beat and it shows up
later that as a moronic move they
understand that they on shaky grounds
and they're not confident with what
they're doing here at least it doesn't
the Optics of it aren't confident I mean
compared to the Silent Hill
announcements that we got yeah you know
they attach names to it like hey blueber
team no code yeah no code and like all
these people that you know from the
industry are working on it you know
we're going back to Silent Hill in a big
way that none of that Pomp and
Circumstance for a franchise that is way
bigger we don't know The Who and we're
worried about the who which naturally
means we kind of don't know the why and
I'm worried about the why why would a
developer who very
deliberately pivoted away from AAA video
games moved into mobile games where
microtransactions were the core business
model and and funnel the Creative Energy
through that kind of lens
suddenly come back to not only
AAA games but start with
the biggest one of the biggest
franchises in the world and then further
down perhaps the biggest entry in that
franchise everything in the way that is
presented feels like this is a smashing
grab I hope it works out I would love
for an a modern Metal Gear Game and some
of the stuff they're saying is very like
it seems like on the right track where
they're like we're gonna stay by the
spirit of it and give it modern
trimmings and push the David hater is or
the original voice cast is back is what
they said I don't think they
specifically said this thing because
David David
was tweeting about his other game
this with Jennifer Hale if people want
to know what video game stuff I'm doing
I'm doing this and I replied saying
anything else question mark
and he did not reply I don't know if
they're re-recording I mean also as well
is are they gonna get paid if they if
they have a remake and they use the same
recordings like
exactly are they going to get paid also
like if they do re-record it how do you
capture that same kind of magic without
the guy who was there helping like the
same casting people like the director I
would love for this to be a scenario
where it's like our konami's version of
the Resident Evil make remix it might
just end up being konami's version of
The Silent Hill 2 remake that they put
out before this one where they
re-released it as an HD Collection it
was absolutely catastrophically broken
the silver lining that putting uh what
are they calling it The masterclass
Master collection yeah it is cheeky like
it is perhaps more damning of of the
approach that Konami has taken they
removed those HD games like two years
ago two years ago or so from digital
libraries and pretty much everywhere
else they said we're gonna relax and so
we're gonna make some edits because of
the archive footage which is
understandable
they didn't put them back they're back
now now you have to pay for it again
which is like are you gonna reinstate
the old ones because I already paid for
this one time yep Smash and grab Smash
and grab Smash and grab the alarm is
going off in my head
so that's why we're a little bit
concerned about Metal Gear Solid
triangle Delta a little bit concerned
big concern big concern but you know
we're going to try and be open-minded
open minds and Open Hearts can't lose so
in terms of other things going on uh
obviously we just did coverage of the
PlayStation showcase uh we've got summer
game Fest coming up but we also are
going to be co-streaming and dreamhack
Dallas June 2nd through 4th right here
on the channel so make sure to tune in
for that and if you're in Dallas or are
able to go tickets are still available
there is a link in the description below
anyway you can find me on Twitter at
Lucy James games and we'll see you next
time Open Hearts open minds